the US Federal Reserve's long
anticipated move was a vote of
confidence in the American economy and
its recovery from the Great Recession of
2008-2009 it also recognizes the
considerable progress that has been made
toward restoring jobs raising incomes
and easing the economic hardship of
millions of Americans and it reflects
the committee's confidence that the
economy will continue to strengthen the
economic recovery has clearly come a
long way although it is not yet complete
muted reaction was felt on global
markets in New York the Dow Industrials
closed one and a quarter percent higher
stocks made modest gains across Asia as
well with japan's nikkei average closing
one-point-six percent higher and hong
kong's hang seng index up eight tenths
of a percent it already is put you know
raising the dollar and therefore putting
downward pressure on emerging market
currencies although I think other
factors are even more important I think
for example the rebalancing in China
away from importing commodities is
having a bigger effect on an emerging
markets by far and causing their
currencies to go down and weakening
their exports overall the feds move is
being seen as a positive for the world
economy a strengthening US economy
should help boost demand for commodities
and industrial goods worldwide